congratulations to both of you I mean
we're top ten narrowing it down to the
top ten this week like you're drilling
behind I just didn't realize that you're
not trolling him there's nothing to talk
about here
I'm just narrowing it down to get
focused on a very small group to take to
the finale but now that hypothetically
speaking I mean how would it feel to
lose to the ladies including your
girlfriend Gwen I like girls a lot more
than a lot guys so I would rather I'd
rather lose to them yeah and not if I
lost to John who I just saw dancing like
a sexy dance and an elf costume that
would be upsetting first takes the
People's Sexiest Man Alive title and now
the voice championship we can't we can't
we can't speak it into existence I gotta
say like just go ahead and kick me in
the night it's a good week heard you got
a cavity show it to us we're gonna keep
it positive there's a lot to be thankful
for this week it is Thanksgiving
what are your guys's plan well we are
going to Oklahoma this will be Holly a
bunch of Thanksgivings in a row in
Oklahoma I want to say the fourth but it
might be more than that taking all the
Stefani's and
and the Shelton bunch are gonna meet up
there and just have literally like five
days same thing you're doing in Montana
just getting away I just you know I do
agree that getting out of this city like
I didn't grow up in a city so like I
grew up in the countryside so it's nice
I like the escape of getting out in like
trees and it's snowing so we're gonna go
snowmobiling and all that stuff so yeah
nature I love it now do you have a
certain dish that maybe you'll whip up
in the kitchen that might impress the
Stefani's no but impress the Stefani I
mean they're Italian and that that's
good I don't even eat a lot of red meat
but it's good maybe I'll try that one
time what it was just a random
circumstance for this model have an
honest house and she was a vegetarian
it's like going down on the ribs and I
was like anyone told her that's me and
that she had a extremely upset stomach
the next day yeah these stories are wild
supermodel Cindy Crawford was at the
house okay did she get an invite back
you're like literally crying happy yes
one eye is just sad today I don't know
why it keeps blowing was it laughter no
it's just leaking I don't know it made
fun of her appendectomy last year or
anything like that or come on let's
lower down
okay don't feel bad I gotta congratulate
her really quick about her Vegas
residency coming up yeah I'm very
excited yeah why was now a moment like
this the time to do a residency nice
tie-in um no I'm not gonna be able to
tour necessarily right now cause of all
the jobs and we have kids and school and
stuff so it's 45 minute flight so it
made sense that I really still want to
do shows and we're releasing music early
2020 so it's somewhere to go to where
fans can kind of come from all over it's
a good time and I love the willow
fortune slot machine and that's where I
was spending all my paychecks you say so
that's where we'll find you at the wheel
of fortune slot machine how addictive
it's the devil's work you're gonna be
good at Vegas
we are going to destroy it thank you
you're gonna be the new Wayne dude we
are we gonna get it get it it's not
we're gonna go see her - yeah we need to
they're winding down so you sure yeah
well she did give you some advice for
the residency she says keep hand
sanitizer on deck
oh that is that's true just now in
general we always are doing that because
I meet so many people on the show and
then there's kids and you know kids are
like petri dishes of sickness just
waiting to explore your body so yeah
Kelly Blake so great to see you guys
congratulations on everything we really
do love you I'm so sorry listen we're
keeping our fingers crossed
I'm depressed leaving this interview
you're gonna win the Grammy and we're
gonna be right there supporting my dogs
that died or when I was a kid or
anything you know no we we're backstage
with you at the CMAs we I mean we tore
your hashtag added alread we did Smith
works we did it all you already built me
up you're saying no we're gonna keep you
out okay
[Music]